[Music]
who's this guy Brett is from Georgia he
was out here in the early days he played
the battlefield soldier in the glitch
Brett was in Footloose now he's back in
LA I needed some help producing this
video and I said come on let's do it
so it's really good to see him I haven't
seen him in years
[Music]
we're gonna go kill some wasps in the
backyard is infested with creepy
crawlies there's only one reasonable
thing you do blast them with raid
[Music]
kilowatt kilowatt I kill the wah wah we
are gonna find the nests of the wasps
they will be terminated without any
public trial it's gonna be great
they're gonna die and then we're never
going to deal with wasps I'm racist
against wasps kill them I got him I'm
drowning in the groaning whoa
t-mike's where's the other one cuz I
just had the most eventful big bear
market run of my entire life so I go
there I'm gonna snag like you know coke
zeros and tsavorite oh nice which are my
favorites but that's all I got on my
trip first off I noticed they had like
new jet lighters on display and stuff
the guys had something in Spanish and
the guys lifted onto any puts a pipe
down like that's a crack pipe
and the guy's like all tatted up and
like super skinny and and like I
was like so that's crazy so I come back
I'm walking down the street this frickin
like land cruiser go pass me one who's
driving 50 got under it suddenly another
honda go pass me looking and they like
they almost collide at the end of the
street I'm like sitting there going what
the landcruiser of the frickin back
stuff the other guy parts locks him in
opens this door and frickin takes up
this huge night and I'm like oh the guy
walks up to the guy and just like in
slices his tire gets in this car goes
off he freakin reverses out of there 50
miles an hour the other guys like who
and like dress starts driving after him
and the tugboat
and goes flat in front of the Vsauce
office knows that I'm sitting there like
dude what's going on today man like
tennis with in Haeundae different
another day man
just another day those a little shocking
man so hunter street back to its roots
man back to its roots do you think it's
getting gentrified all the hipsters are
moving no dudes crack pipe Ali still
street fights knife fights all the good
stuff
oh hey guess what's in the corridor
store fresh in stock go check it out
[Music]
t-mike's
where's the other one right there and
the flowers I can't kill the flowers you
go in the lrc he's been calling areas
you bastard
your bastard not dead yet yeah I would
attack
Oh
[Music]
there it is
kilowatt I killed a lot I killed a lot
after the loss it was a disaster for the
wasp I'm telling you
end of the story end of the line is you
just don't mess with the best you know
human beings we are the best we are
clear the keepers of nature we dominate
all so I had to show them who's boss no
day in life of a court or employee what
else can I say